thank you so much for auditioning on the
show and for singing such a beautiful
song and
you know it was
we love you
simon cowell got emotional during
wednesday's episode of america's got
talent after former contestant nightbird
returned to the show to thank the judges
and the fans
i cannot say thank you enough for the
opportunity to
to have a moment to share my story the
talented singer whose real name is jane
marcheski earned the golden buzzer from
simon during the second night of season
16 auditions and
i'm not going to give you a yes
[Music]
i'm gonna give you something else
[Music]
but she revealed earlier this month that
she was exiting the competition to focus
on her health amid her ongoing cancer
battle
you made the decision rightly so that
your health is your priority right now
and i know that the last time we spoke
you actually said you feel like you let
people down well i just want to say on
behalf of all of us you haven't let
anyone down
even though you haven't competed you've
already won the clip of nightbird's
audition where she's saying her original
tune it's okay has been viewed over 31
million times
okay it's okay it's okay it's okay
[Music]
it's something the thirty-year-old says
she never could have seen coming it's a
song i wrote for myself in the middle of
the night when i needed those words so
bad
and it's um
it's beautiful to see
the world
welcome that song into their own dark
night and
i
i'm overwhelmed by it that's when simon
chimed in and became increasingly
emotional your clip has had such an
impact on so many people and your
courage and who you are and the most
important thing is your well-being in
your health and your recovery and on
behalf of all of us here we're sending
you our love our prayers and we can't
wait to see you again soon and thank you
so much for auditioning on the show and
for singing such a beautiful song and
you know it was
we love you
and if all that wasn't sweet enough
nightbird went on to thank the judges
for the opportunity i think it's
restored my faith in humanity a whole
lot to see people come together
just over the fact that we all hurt we
all suffer and we all have the potential
to to overcome and um
it's this is
i mean
the most beautiful thing that's ever
happened to me in my life the singer
took to instagram on august 2nd to
reveal that she chose to step away from
the season and that her health had quote
taken a turn for the worse
quote sharing my heart with the world on
agt has been an honor and a dream come
true neighborhood added quote life
doesn't always give breaks to those that
deserve it but we knew that already she
concluded her post thanking fans for
their support writing quote stay with me
i'll be better soon i'm planning my
future not my legacy
it's okay it's okay it's okay it's okay
if you're lost we're all a little lost
and it's all right
it's all right it's all right it's all
right
[Music]